we begin in India where police have
raided the homes of several journalists
at more than 30 locations in and around
New Delhi the journalists are associated
with the news website news click a case
has been filed against the outlet under
an anti-terror law it comes after the
New York Times alleged back in August
that news click received funding from a
businessman linked to China and promoted
Pro Beijing talking points the
journalists say police have confiscated
their laptops and phones media Watchdog
reporters Without Borders placed India
at the 161st Place in its latest press
Freedom rankings this
year well the association the largest
Association of journalists in India has
reacted on the social media platform X
it said the Press Club of India is
deeply concerned about the multiple
raids conducted on the houses of
journalists and writers associated with
news click and they say they are
monitoring developments and will be
releasing a more detailed statement
let's go to showb Danielle he joins us
now from New Delhi he's a political
editor at scroll News website thank you
for joining the program why do you think
these journalists have been
targeted so this is actually part of a
pattern against civil liberty that the
Modi government has run for the past
decade or so um uh the the case against
news leag actually been wrong running
and earlier involved uh a case of
foreign funds being transferred under
Draconian enforcement directorate laws
and now that's been widen to an
anti-terror case after as you pointed
out the New York Times published an
article in August alleging that new news
click had received Chinese
funds so uh this is part of the Modi
government's politics around muscular
nationalism mus muscular National
Security and as you can see this is
playing out hugely in India today across
the news channels uh along these lines
as you say the authorities say they've
used this anti-terror law to justify
these raids I mean does that make sense
to you that they've used uh
anti-terrorism laws to Target these
journalists well yes and no at any moral
level it does not uh the journalists
being raided uh are being raided I mean
across the board even if you even if you
were to for a minute believe these
allegations uh at at at at work first
you could have targeted the management
of the website but what we're seeing
right now is even Junior employees are
getting raided even contributors are
getting raided which is absolutely
frankly ridiculous uh the the yes comes
from the fact that India has an
extremely Draconian Terror law regime
where people can be arrested and locked
away for years without trial and we've
been seeing that with civil rights
activists you know across India there
have been multiple cases where uh rather
flimsy allegations have been made and
people locked up under India ter law
which is called the uapa which is what
is being used here so uh legally
unfortunately uh there is isn't a lot to
push back against this sort of action
the way India's laws and courts have
interpreted
this and tell us a bit more what you
think about these New York Times
allegations uh about the funding of this
website uh that it comes from a US
millionaire who is pushing some sort of
Chinese propaganda I mean what is what
is your understanding do you use this
website what more can you tell us about
it and and and and is it illegal in any
way for over overseas funding um for a
News website in
India so that's a defense that news
click has given that even if these
allegations that the New York Times has
made are true uh there is nothing
illegal that it has done uh and of
course we'll only find that out at the
end of the trial but the way India's
legal system is sort of built uh you
know that that that final verdict might
come after so many years uh that uh in a
way the process is the punishment the
fact that these cases have been launched
that these charges have been made
against news click and these raids have
been made and potential arrest could
also be made that itself would be so
punitive and remember news click is a
very small news organization that
Independent News organization that
itself would be extremely harmful not
only news click but the idea of press
freedom India because then you can based
on uh these sort of allegations you
could really uh go after any media house
or journalist in India and as we were
reporting earlier this year India
slipped in the world press Freedom index
it's now 161 out of 180 what is your
experience when it comes to press
Freedom press Freedom has indeed taken a
huge hit over the last decade India was
always I mean India was always a
function democracy and we always had a
push and pull when it came to press
Freedom uh but over the last decade what
we're seeing is that even a sort of
facade that the government used to put
forward in helping protect journalists
and helping protect journalism is gone
you can see that journalism itself
nowadays is becoming increasingly a
crime if you're on the wrong side of the
Divide uh you could be raided you could
be arrested you could be charged with uh
a ly of offenses uh and remember it's a
state on the other side so they have an
infinite amount of resources and very
often the journalists who are
independent and are reporting uh you
know against Power they don't have a lot
of resources so it's a really it's a
really chilling uh it has a chilling
effect honestly on journalism in India
you know you could arrest one person but
you could using that you could actually
silence hundreds of journalists who
would genuinely and understandably be
scared about the safety of themselves
and their families I appreciate your
time and speaking to us here on Al jaaz
shab Danielle uh a political editor at
the scroll News website speaking to us
there from New Delhi